thank you
[Music]
I think I think I just found the [ __ ]
coolest dude is it a picture of this guy
right here
that's close I I should be on I should
be close I think top three what do you
think this guy's whole thing is like
look how [ __ ] gnarly oh he's a
vampire yeah he's a wrestler at Hot
Topic
is he a vampire is that Steve I mean
he's there in the daytime
he's you should be out at night he he is
a he is a 42 year old bodyguard who
identifies as a vampire that's sick I
[ __ ] with that but he's in he's out in
the daytime well he actually does have
there's like a disease that makes your
skin burn really like bad and fast when
you're in the Sun and he actually
coincidentally has that disease is that
why people disease yeah it's pretty wild
that bill ligo it's not even like he's
just an Irish guy but this guy really
does in terms of people who like walk
the walk when they like say they
identify something he does exactly that
this dude has been drinking the blood of
his loved ones for 20 years whoa that's
it and you know what I'm all for it when
you become close enough to him like as a
friend he literally will ask like
consent to get your blood drawn so that
he can drink it who who's he guarded
that's what I want to know too
who's he guarding he doesn't have a
client list because wherever that is we
should kill him because they're the
vampire King
his job is to protect Beyonce right and
if Beyonce wants to go to Jamaica to
have fun like dude that's such a hard
thing for him to do he probably
shouldn't cloak and you probably can't
fly with pints of blood and you're like
that's your food it's like being vegan
dude it's like man you make it so
[ __ ] difficult to just do normal
stuff check it back you got to keep it
under four ounces he said that he's he's
uh in the past like two decades he's
drank like 20 something pints of blood
whoa yeah this is it hardcore at least
just walk on the walk does he mix it
with anything like put some sweetener in
or something no but I mean Shake no he
doesn't but he he said he can tell the
difference like based on your diet what
your blood tastes like he's like
somebody's had some pineapples
a little more salty or like gross but he
said that like I don't even want to
taste it plus you you know you can't you
can't really ingest a lot of blood at
one time as a human like you're just
gonna [ __ ] yourself like if you drink
too much no it goes It goes that's what
land that's not what liver King says
he's pretty swole though maybe maybe
it's good like instead of protein shakes
he just drinks that and it's got a lot
of
I like the the idea of him being a
bodyguard and then the other like people
find out and they're like oh my God he
can't be killed this guy's Immortals
yeah aren't you getting like 70 plasma
only when you're drinking blood
what does that mean
electrolytes like are there like
nutritious properties that like one
would think I'd be hyped to have this
guy as a bodyguard it's really I'd be
scared of my own bodyguard bodyguard's a
vampire bro [ __ ] with me bite my ass
yeah what if we get lost in the jungle
and he's hungry you know he's gonna
[ __ ] suck on you the last thing you
want is a [ __ ] high maintenance
bodyguard too that's why it's like I
gotta put hairspray in my top hat on and
[ __ ] it's a special diet I'm like you
need to dodge a bullet for me you can't
be over here [ __ ] iron in your velvet
suit which high maintenance you say that
until he [ __ ] moves hella quick and
[ __ ] like vampires are you can't see his
reflection in the mirror and stuff and
you get shot he comes up to him yeah no
you're killing me more
give me some of it back
yeah it's crazy because he said he uh he
started by drinking his own blood to
kind of like get used to it and that's
the gateway drug we all did that when we
could we picked the scap we're like oh
it's [ __ ] bleeding and then we suck
on it and then I was like I'm a vampire
has tried finding his lame disease to
make it cool and he's like I'm gonna
guess I'm a vampire it's not Rebrand it
sure yeah you know that's a good way to
cope right yeah I can't see the sun why
I'm a vampire yeah and he stuck with it
do you think like can he what about
mirrors what if he sees himself in the
reflection doesn't that like he'll
probably say that that's just a
romanticized version of yeah how are you
gonna have killer hair like if you can't
even do it in front of the mirror yeah
oh yeah he also has a good question he
also has his friends like if he's gonna
get blood from him they have to like do
the HIV and AIDS test before it gives it
sounds like a lot of work to be vampires
don't give a real good vampires don't
give a [ __ ] about that yeah
I just suck on any debt anyway I don't
care about that sensitive vampires
aren't immune to AIDS or anything like
that
they're Immortal dude that [ __ ] didn't
even exist for like until like the 80s
right yeah
yeah I I wonder if he eats garlic bread
they're not supposed to eat garlic right
exactly yeah
or silver he's got see that's I don't
like that sticky utensils I bet every
day of his life he has to defend why
he's a vampire which can get exhausted
and he should he shouldn't have to
defend him if you make that choice if he
was my client and I'm all like dude I
got you some new jewelry and then like
it's like I got it from nothing but
silver and then he's got like these
skull rings and [ __ ] and his hand goes
and I'm like oh my bad I forgot you're a
vampire [ __ ] you know if he commits like
that good bro I'd be impressed I'd be
impressed steam things in his hand just
to make you stop now I believe that I'll
give it to him I think he's committed
enough Liv he's pretty committed yeah we
better run if he sees Wesley Snipes then
yep because he's always kind of run the
other way you'll get him Jay Walker
imagine he's your bodyguard okay and you
have to perform at the Gilroy Garlic
this is sort of what you do it's kind of
your move huh
when you want to go golfing that's what
you say this is literally the guy who
shows up half the time
we took him out
what are you talking about
the Las Vegas Nevada time goes oh guys I
got a flight at 7 45 can we end on time
please wait that's him that's me he
started it and I said yeah me too you
got the texture seeds present
so you see how you just derailed the
topic of this video by just trying to
dunk on [ __ ] a lukewarm joke it was
worth every second of it I don't regret
anything I would do it again I'll do it
I'll do it again and again can you go
back to the garlic Gilroy [ __ ] that was
a pretty good that was a pretty good one
what's going on
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if you asked him like oh how come you
can see yourself how come you don't
sleep in confidence and you asked him
those other things that maybe he didn't
feel like were comfortable enough to do
a guy like this would just go those are
just the vampires in books I love the
way we really live oh damn you kind of
sold that and then he turns into a
[ __ ] band and flies away
vampire
we're a little more modern now is there
like a dating app for like these people
you know what I mean like other people
that identify people bro
what do you mean why'd you say it was
such this
disc
dude
so do you think so a guy like this like
would you feel like you know what
there's different types of groups that
identifies different things needing more
rights would you support him nope to
identify as a vampire yeah if he was
like I don't like that there's no
vampiric pronouns like would you oh dude
they can't Mars during the day you're
gonna March at night that's gonna be
annoying Define in this lifestyle this
time frame what a vampire is because I
only got a book vampire he would say why
why should a human Define what a vampire
is I think leave it up to the vamps
go to the vaps and go [ __ ] talk it
out yeah
I want my own parking because I I can't
walk very far they're bandicap look work
yeah I don't think you want them to have
like a vampire Council that always goes
bad yeah that's true I saw blade I saw
blade or we just need to consult with
the lichens you know what I mean yeah I
remember Deacon Frost man yeah
that guy was [ __ ] serious they use a
lot of sunblock he took himself a little
too seriously at Deacon Frost because
when the werewolf committee comes out
they're gonna be like why do they get
all the [ __ ] rights yeah like of
course the vampire get all love again
and if he's a real vampire how old is he
he should be at least he's a real
vampire a thousand years old dude he
should be [ __ ] millions of years old
if he identifies as a vampire Twilight
vampire yeah Team Jacob what if he's new
though isn't wasn't Kristen Stewart a
new Vamp yeah that's true she got she
got turned yeah yeah that's not weak
[ __ ] though he turned himself at age 20.
she's also like 17 the whole time like
uh oh he turned it's 20 so for 20 years
he wasn't a vampire not because I mean
he got bit no he just he he bit himself
he began identifying as one 20 years ago
he's not even a pure blood come on man
he's a mud blood yeah dude it sounds
like he doesn't do any bodyguarding at
all he's doing vampire stuff yeah sounds
like he's our clients this [ __ ]
probably got like student dead and [ __ ]
he's out here playing around
it's cosplaying go watch this job and
pay off your goddamn debt and also those
those photo shoots he's doing they look
expensive you know quality and what if
everybody who identifies as a vampire
has to submit their origin story though
and it's like a legit one just say quit
playing around
what would have been hardcore this guy
is if is if all the pictures of him were
just the landscape because you can't
take a picture of a [ __ ] man yeah he
should have done that his clothes is
floating it just looks like Windows
wallpapers
anytime people go full out like
steampunk or like [ __ ] goth or
whatever it looks sick when they're in
the forest right put them in Subway
you're gonna be like put them in the
modern world put them at 7-Eleven they
look like a dork dude yeah taquitos it's
not like blade it's like not a lot of
people look that cool Batman doesn't
work during the day or at conventions
100 it looks really bad yeah that's true
like that he's a good vampire he's a
bodyguard it's pretty cool right I don't
think he has a clown on your side I'm
not buying it why don't you hire him
what's his Yelp what's his jail his
bodyguarding yeah do you have a website
he doesn't have a website how do you
quit playing around.com
I think metal bands would hire him his
name is Joseph Burris
yeah kind of vampy yeah yeah yeah I'm
back on board a little bit yeah okay
yeah he would look in his element at a
metal concert or like one of it's like
he he has to just be in the trick is
that Subway like he said dude you can't
look hard at Subway you ain't hard
that's a true Club he might be a word of
mouth kind of higher because I don't see
any place to like recruit him no digital
footprint bro I picture a biker hiring
him
yeah yeah bikers shouldn't need their
own yeah bicyclists what if he's like
what if it's like a body go for like a
politician oh you know I'm saying yeah
that's kind of interesting
[Music]